Hello, I'm Scotty Meyer and this is
Ankit.
>> [laughter]
>> Was I supposed to introduce myself?
It's my friend Janique. What's up?
>> [laughter]
[music]
>> Origins of Halloween. Origins. What do
you know about origins?
>> Halloween comes from Samhain, which is
an ancient Gaelic
harvest festival. Mhm. And it was a time
where people got together [music]
together and they built fires and
celebrated and they tried to ward off
ghosts. That's where we get the idea of
dressing up because they thought if they
dressed up as ghosts, then they would
scare the evil spirits away. And so, you
know, lots of things that we do today
actually come from that. It was
adopted by the Catholic Church by Pope
Gregory the III who He came up with the
Day of the Dead, basically.
>> All Saints' Day. Uh, yeah. Which is
November 1 and that's where a lot of
those pagan things that happened [music]
on Samhain made it into the church. The
Celtics were conquered by the Romans,
right? And eventually out of the Romans
came the Roman Catholic Church
>> [music]
>> and the Romans started blending their
pagan beliefs with some of these Celtic
beliefs like this ancient festival and
then the Roman Catholic Church came with
All Saints' Day like you were saying and
that's what we have today. What country
does Halloween originate from Oh, come
from? Oh, well, I was close enough.
Ireland.
Okay. That's it. Can Christians
Can Christians celebrate Halloween? No.
>> Is that really the number one most
Googled thing?
>> It is Well,
Halloween and Christian
>> So So, wait a minute. I think Christians
can but they shouldn't.
>> There you go.
Is it okay
for Christians to give out
candy?
Ooh.
Oh.
I like candy. But
>> He does like candy. Context. Context is
important. Probably not a good idea.
Why? Why not give out a toothbrush?
Oh, yeah. How about a low tract? I mean,
his wife is a dental hygienist, so that
makes sense.
>> How about a tract on spiritualism? We
actually have some of those. We should
insert a commercial right here.
>> [music]
>> You might experience something similar
this year hearing those familiar words.
Trick or treat.
But instead of giving them a trick or a
treat, give them truth. Get our new
sharing cards on spiritualism and
witchcraft and give them something
better.
>> [music]
>> Can Christians dress up
>> in an innocent costume? Good question.
Yeah, so I mean, I guess you could, but
you know, dressing up as a character on
Halloween essentially comes from an
ancient Gaelic holiday Samhain or
whatever it's called. Yeah, that's
Samhain, I think. And they dressed up to
ward off evil spirits. That's [music]
essentially what you're perpetuating. Is
Halloween
Christian?
No.
>> No.
Is Halloween satanic?
Wow.
Should we even answer that? You should
answer it. You get the piano music like
the elevator music. Do do do do do do do
do do do do do do do
>> [music]
>> Yes, of course it's satanic.
>> have scary sounds right there.
Halloween
dead people can we see them? I like what
the Bible says [music] in Isaiah 8:19
and 20. Actually, I'm going to pull that
out and read it. And when they say to
you, "Seek those who are mediums and
wizards who [music] whisper and mutter,
should not a people seek their God?
Should they seek the dead on behalf of
the living? To the law and to the
testimony. If they [music] do not speak
according to this word, it is because
there is no light in them." Why do we
want to seek out dead people? The
Bible's even asking us that question.
[music]
Shouldn't we be seeking God instead of
seeking the dead? And of course, we've
made lots of videos about what happens
when you die, so you [music] can check
out some of those probably in
some link
or
somebody will make it appear on this
edited video. Um, I don't think the
average person sees dead people. Well,
yeah, the average person, but
>> Yeah. Have you seen that clip about the
the the former Satanist? Halloween is
the highest day on the satanic calendar.
It is also the night of the year where
there is the most human sacrifice on the
whole planet.
Halloween meaning. Oh, Halloween
meaning. [music] So, the word etymology
is actually hallow, which means holy or
blessed.
>> Yep. Um, which [music] is why they have
like the Hallow app. That's where that
comes from.
>> Oh, we have a video about that on our
channel. Plug.
>> That word, I think is also the word
[music] that's used like in Genesis when
it talks about God creating the Sabbath.
So, he blessed and hallowed it. That's
why they put it in the King James.
[music] So, Halloween, the the een part
is actually short for like eve, so it's
like All Hallows' Eve and it's got
mashed into the what we know as
Halloween. [music] So.
>> And like we said, this was All Hallows'
Eve, which was like um All
the night before All [music] Saints'
Day. Yeah. So, and that was meshed with
the original Celtic/Roman
festival. Halloween night spiritual
things that [music]
can happen. I also had a friend who
worked for the sheriff's department and
he said he encountered things that would
happen on those nights and a lot of this
stuff doesn't actually make it into the
news.
What does the Bible say about Halloween?
It does talk about, for example, that
we're not supposed to seek out mediums
and and and witches and all those kind
of people. The word Halloween isn't
mentioned [music] in the Bible, but many
of the practices or or principles around
Halloween are talked about in the Bible.
Yeah, so. And very much spoken
against. Why do we carve pumpkins?
Well,
>> know the answer to this.
Jack-o'-lantern, it actually comes from
Irish folklore. It's about a man named
[music] Stingy Jack and he, according to
the story, tricked the devil twice
because he was a sinner and he didn't
want to pay the price. So, Jack
apparently wasn't allowed into heaven
cuz he was bad, but he also wasn't
allowed into hell. So, what happened was
is that the devil gave him a small
burning coal to light his path. [music]
And the only thing that he had available
to him was a pumpkin because there's no
watermelons at that time of the year.
Well,
there were no pumpkins in Ireland at the
time.
>> Oh, okay.
>> This is an American thing, okay?
>> Okay. So, so Jack
runs around with his coal and he's
trying to light his path and he's like,
uh, I've got turnips over here cuz that
was a vegetable they grew out there, not
pumpkins. Right. And so, he carves the
the turnip and puts the coal in there
to, you know, make a better life for
himself, I guess. He was named after
that lantern, so Jack with the lantern,
which later was shortened into
Jack-o'-lantern. So, that whole
tradition with the Irish people, they
came to the United States. They started
carving pumpkins instead and here we are
carving pumpkins. Going back to Ireland,
the Irish people actually carved faces
out of turnips to scare off Jack's soul,
his spirit. So, technically, when we're
participating carving a bunch of
pumpkins, you know, cuz remember the
Irish came to the United States and
started carving pumpkins,
you're actually doing it to ward off
demons, spirits.
Kind of scary. That is kind of scary and
weird. Why do we dress up for Halloween
origin? [music]
Again, that goes back to Samhain. People
dressed up as ghosts, but that's why
people do that. It's cuz they were
dressing up as [music] ghosts to scare
off Yep. evil spirits out there. Let you
take the next one. All right, so can
churches
carve Uh, I was going to say pumpkin.
Oh, a fall festivals. Hm. The whole idea
of carving faces out of pumpkins and
turnips was to ward off demons. Sure.
So, do you think then that [music] it's
okay for us to start carving pumpkins
when we know that it was originally
meant to ward off demons? Context is
important.
>> Yes. I agree with you. No, you should
not. Halloween decorations, right? Yeah.
Um, actually that that satanic former
Satanist who became a Christian,
he talks about how if you have Halloween
decorations around your house and all of
that, it's it's an invitation for the
spirits to come in. I would agree with
that. In a neighborhood or area,
there's houses, there's homes that
celebrate Halloween where they put up
the decorations and they do the pumpkins
and they do the candles and the candy,
those things, right? And it's fun. Let's
say in a neighborhood, there is houses
that do that.
So, that whole perimeter
becomes one big satanic ritual for that
whole neighborhood. Wait, wait, wait.
So, you're telling me because I've got
them already up. It's September. There's
I mean, there's skeletons, there's
creepy stuff in our neighborhood
already. So, [music] you're saying my
neighborhood right now is cooked? Like
what What are you saying there?
So, I'm saying that in a in a
neighborhood or a or a area perimeter
where there is
a few homes,
that is already a set up as in terms of
a hot spot for demonic activity.
As anybody, whether they're Christian or
non-Christian, that have open doors,
that moves or lives in a neighborhood
like that will be affected. That's what
I'm saying. Okay, so what do we do as
Christians?
So, firstly, we make sure that we are in
righteous standing with God, that we do
not have any hidden sin or open doors in
our life, that we are in a righteous
covenant with him.
And then it is about praying
like being in serious pray
that people who celebrate Halloween,
um whether they speaking being a
Satanist or a atheist or someone having
fun, that whilst they're doing that,
that they will actually have a true
encounter with Christ.
Here we go. Christians' alternative for
Halloween. There actually is an
alternative for Halloween. Well, it's
Reformation Day [music] on the 31st.
>> It is Reformation Day.
>> It's the day that Martin Luther nailed
the 95 theses into the door of the
Wittenberg Church, and that was the
basically the start of the Protestant
Reformation, and [music] that's
celebrated on the 31st as well. So,
there's actually a really cool church
that does this every year that we're
familiar with. We know of the It's the
Apison Seventh-day Adventist Church.
>> in the local Chattanooga area
Chattanooga, Tennessee. There you go.
There you go. Here we go. Moving on. Is
Is witchcraft real?
Yes. Absolutely. It's a complete answer.
Yes. Go to our channel and click on the
playlist witchcraft and you'll see it.
>> Is it bad to dress up as a witch for
Halloween? Yes. Yes. I I really believe
and we hear it from the horse's mouth
from a former Satanist that this is uh
the devil's holiday. In fact, Anton
LaVey, the founder of the Church of
Satan, he actually says Thank you,
parents, for letting our children
uh worship or or celebrate the devil
once a year. I mean, if he says it, you
know it's not from God. You know it's
from Satan. Stay away from it. And if
you think about it on the other side of
the fence, like I'm sure people who grew
up in witchcraft are not like, "Ooh,
let's just go to church one day a week,
right?" Yeah, let's say let's celebrate
Jesus once a year. They don't do that.
Stay close to Jesus. Fair enough.
Wow, left me hanging.
>> Oh, left me hanging. Boom, blow it up.
Wow.
>> [music]
[music]